i can't speak for every state of in the
union about exactly what their voting
right and laws are but there are things
in that bill that are mandated that
florida already does we already have
early voting okay we have a 14-day
period a 13-day period of early voting
and then you've got anybody can vote by
mail in florida you don't have to prove
that you're going to be out of town or
whatever and then you've got election
day you go to your precinct and from 7
a.m to 7 00 p.m as long as you're in
line before 7 pm you can vote that way
so it's never been easier but when i
first ran for office in 2010 there was
still you know early voting was at one
point in the state limited didn't even
exist 20 years ago right then when i
first voted in 19 my first election 1989
there was no early voting if you wanted
to vote absentee you had to write a
letter saying i'm going to be out of
town or i'm having surgery or whatever
it is on that day
and so i don't think it's ever been
easier to either register or to vote in
florida
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
with my first interview from the free
state of florida and we got the right
guy for it florida senator marco rubio
senator how are you
i'm good glad to have you here and and
just a disclaimer at the outset this is
like real world right here i'm in my
backyard i got my dog is right here so
if you hear a little barking that's why
i'm using these but uh
we're not trying to stage anything here
it's all real man so i apologize ahead
if he barks you're going full florida
man so first off as you as you know i
just moved here from the crazy state of
california i've been here for a couple
weeks just moved into the house i'm in
my makeshift studio now you were nice
enough to uh to do a little promo video
for me welcoming me here so let's just
start with the state of florida first i
mean what is it about florida that
sort of allowed florida to do it right
over these last two years like i don't
think it's just the political part
although that's a part of it what is it
about just sort of the florida man the
florida woman that that did something
right here
that's a great question i do think it
starts with political leadership and
maybe the the truth is that the the
people produce that political leadership
they reward a certain kind of leadership
and don't reward others but
you know i think the key thing about
florida understand is that everyone's
from somewhere else for the most part
and that means another part of the
country like you and mayor
hundreds of thousands of people in
florida that have done what you've done
and that is you came here because you
didn't like what life was like under the
leadership of people in some other state
and so when people come to a place to
get away from that kind of stuff they
came for a reason so i think that's a
big part of it and it's not just from
other states we also have people that
come from other countries so here in
south florida as i'm sure you've already
experienced we have a lot of people that
obviously came from cuba or their
parents did and then venezuela and
nicaragua and so any time that there is
or for that matter you know any time
there's any sort of left-wing disruption
in latin america so for example peru
elected a president who's far left and
even anti-american and suddenly you see
the real estate purchases from peruvian
skyrocket
people come here to get away from that
stuff they come here from other
countries they come here from other
states and i think that's a big big part
of
of what makes florida what it is and
it's something we really need to protect
you know and it's a dynamic state in
many ways it's sort of a 21st century
frontier state in that way well listen
man i am here to protect it as i keep
telling people i'm here to keep i'm here
to keep florida florida i have noticed
you know you mentioned the international
part of this i mean one thing i've
definitely noticed in a couple weeks
here especially in the miami area i mean
everyone brings their own driving
customs here there is a certain set of
ways that you drive in florida that i
have not seen in california before
yeah i mean it's all it's always the
game about you know can i beat the red
light or is it you know it's all like a
10-second rule on the red light you know
like the light is red but does it really
mean red or do i get something like you
drop something on the floor you get a
you know it's a two-second rule whatever
same thing with that um you know
everybody's trying to figure out how to
use a back street to cut through traffic
um there's a little bit of that you know
and it's part of the flare of the place
i'm not encouraging people to do it but
it's part of the sort of the character
of it i think that's true probably more
in south florida than in other parts of
the state but um
but it is uh yeah i know it's different
no i've never um i've definitely become
a bit of a venezuelan or cuban driver
already in a couple weeks here but in
these last two years that that florida
continued to flourish while so many
states collapsed and as you said there
are quite literally hundreds of
thousands of people moving in this
direction right now
what do you do
to stop people who made the mistakes in
the blue states from repeating those
mistakes here i'm not going to repeat
those mistakes but you know obviously
some people will
yeah i think first of all it's
self-selective i mean you know i'm not
saying that's true for everybody but the
frankly the bottom line is this if you
live in california and you watch msnbc
habitually you spend all day on twitter
you think that in florida we have bodies
all over the streets and we have you
know people are just dying left and
right and governor desantis is the
leader of a death cult so you're not
going to move to florida if that's what
you think unless some your job makes you
or something so by and large people that
are moving here are people that are they
don't believe that stuff uh when they
come now that doesn't mean that's true
for everybody and look this is a
state with diverse opinions but look
this has always been a state that's had
liberals this has always been a state
that's had people that are left of
center
on their political views but i don't
think that's the dividing line anymore i
mean i think you can be a liberal and
not be crazy i think what we're talking
about now is things that go well beyond
just traditional i want higher taxes and
more government
this is the complete total abandonment
of common sense of balance of the reason
and and almost so hysteria on on its
approach to different issues and and um
and i do think we've avoided a lot of
that happening here that doesn't mean
it's not present at all but i i don't
see a lot of that happening i mean you
know that there aren't people that hold
those views or to talk in those ways but
but but i think what's really important
is to show the results right at the end
of the day there's a reason why
ocasio-cortez and and you know all these
other members of congress come down here
to vacation and party on new year's eve
and it and it's because you know they
may be in favor of the rules or at least
publicly in favor of the rules in their
home state but when it comes time to
actually enjoy life they're coming here
they're not going to some of these other
places and um
and so i think reminding people that and
and comparing you know us to these other
states and what they're going through
is one of the most important things we
can continue to do to convince people
and win this battle do you ever envy
the fact that the democrats can get away
with virtually anything like aoc can be
partying down here at clubs you know
mass lists and the whole thing while
she's locking down her own people when
clearly if you were to do anything that
the media could figure out in some
slight way was hypocritical or when say
senator cruz went on a vacation that was
long planned for a couple days they go
bananas but democrats can pretty much do
anything do you ever get a little
jealous of that
you know that's a great question and let
me tell you what happens and i can talk
to you about my evolution on all of this
i think when you first kind of get into
politics you know i got elected ten
years ago and i get there and i'm new to
the place and all that and so
whether it's the people around you or
just your own instincts you sort of
think all right you guys yes they're
left of center and they're liberal but
at some point there's some fairness in
them right and
and so i think you waste a lot of time
thinking you're going to impress people
you know from in the in their legacy
media and i think that's worse than it's
ever been when i when i and in terms of
the their bias and so forth
and and i think maybe one of the things
that donald trump revealed is you're
never going to impress these people i
mean you're they're never going to treat
you the same as as they do the other
side i think once you abandon that and
once you accept it that's a fact and
then the next step is realizing by the
way a lot of people know this like
there's a lot of people out there that
notice this double standard and so i
always chuckle about things like for
example you know i look i ran for
president i finished in third place in
the delegate count i made it all the way
to florida it didn't turn out the way i
wanted it to but that was god's plan for
for our country and for my life and i
you know things uh a lot of things i've
been able to do over the last four years
i wouldn't have been able to do if i had
won that race or never been the nominee
and uh and you know they called me up
for a long time they wrote about marco
rubio failed presidential candidate
you know kamala harris didn't even make
it out of california she didn't even
make it to december
zero
yeah cory booker didn't even make it to
descend they'd even make it to the first
state and they're called former
presidential candidates so i'm a failed
one they're a former one i don't care
but it's an example of that sort of
double standard and and it exists and i
think there comes a point where you kind
of realize who cares like it doesn't
really matter people
say people see it and frankly people
don't believe it anymore we're just not
living in an era now there are more
people that will watch this podcast then
we'll read you know what the local
newspaper writes about me on any given
day and and once you sort of realize
that uh it makes life a lot easier you
know
yeah you know so with some of the covid
stuff here because to your point if you
watch msnbc they may or read the new
york times they make it sound like
everyone's dying in florida i'll tell
you very straight up i got covered right
when i got here my whole staff got
covered i was able to get monoclonal
treatment it took literally about an
hour
i was able to get ivermectin i was sick
for a couple days and then i was better
it was just fine that's not to say that
covet doesn't exist here of course it
does
but that's in stark contrast to a place
like california or new york where you
can't really get those treatments i mean
first off they want you to have a
positive test to get the treatment but
then you can't even get the test so when
you guys were putting together the
policy on all of this and and when you
were talking to the governor and the
other health officials
how much pressure did you feel to like
we don't want to be the one state that
is a little more open but then we we end
up being the one that really screws it
up
well look i mean there's a lot of credit
to be deserved by the governor i mean he
he took uh he took some chances here in
terms of what was being told to him from
the you know the national media versus
what what he decided to do on the basis
of the information he had and that moved
to
make
a monoclonal antibodies available to
people not not just not just that they
got sick but even if they've been
exposed to it i think saved a lot of
lives and kept a lot of people out of
hospitals it really did and and um i
know that firsthand from people that
went through it i think that was a major
move and an important one and uh why
other states didn't follow suit you know
i don't know i i can tell you that where
we got into a kind of involved in it at
that point is which when the federal
government under joe biden realized
florida's making us look bad and so they
decided we're going to start rationing
this we're going to start making sure
that each state gets a certain amount
but they don't you know even if they're
not using it they'll allow it for them
in essence a way to restrict florida's
access to it
and at least for some of those drugs you
the state could directly negotiate with
a company but there are some others
especially the newer ones where you got
to go through the federal government and
that's at the point where we really got
concerned because uh you know when the
federal government starts saying we're
gonna start rationing this
what you realize is they're doing it to
punish florida they're doing it to make
sure that florida doesn't continue to
embarrass them by making this an
effective way to pursue this and um and
uh but but yeah you know look ultimately
it's not just about comparing us to
other states i mean you don't want
anybody to die or get sick but life is
about the management of risk
there's benefits there's rewards and
there's risks associated to virtually
everything we'll do at some point today
you and i and others will get in the car
and drive somewhere and there's real
risk involved in that and maybe more
here than other places right but but
there's risk involved in it
but
there are things you just have to be
able to do in life and um and and in
order to live
and and i think once you make public
policy from that perspective it allows
you to make decisions like that
where are you at with using the levers
of power at this point when it comes to
you know there's still a lot of kids in
masks in schools here not all the
schools it's a little unclear to me if
that's left to the counties at this
point or the mayor's or there's
obviously some level of school choice in
private public school all of that what
do you think should be happening are you
trying to push one way or another or
where are you at
yeah you know ultimately in my view i i
think one of the things that this
pandemic revealed is the importance of
local government and local control to
make those decisions and so right now at
the state level schools are being told
you can't have a mass mandate so as an
example the public schools here in
miami-dade have a mass mandate for
employees but not for the kids and
there's a lot of reason that private
schools can make their own decisions
right so i have one kid who's in a
public charter school and they don't
have a mass mandate i have my older sons
in a private catholic high school and
they do but i can tell you a couple
things about it the first is that again
it's a risk and reward balancing
prospect let me be frank like the way
these kids wear the masks on a you know
12 to 20 hour basis whenever around the
school isn't exactly you know the way
you're supposed to wear them if they're
even effective at all in that sense so
that's the reality so you start thinking
there's okay they're not they're not
going to wear the mask the way they're
supposed to anyway all we're doing is
creating an additional irritant um in
their educational setting and so you
hope there's some common sense into how
that's enforced and then i think when
you talk about this omicron variant it
ultimately isn't i mean if you talk to
people who will speak to you honestly
about it the masks aren't going to stop
this this is a highly infectious variant
luckily it's not as severe but it is
highly infectious and there are just
things that aren't going to work against
it and and um so so my view of it is i
leave it to the to the states and the
school boards to make those decisions
but i would hope they would make those
decisions with the best interests of the
kids in mind i'd much i'm much more
worried about them not learning how to
read and write than i am about them not
wearing the mask exactly right you know
with the thing notched over their nose
and and especially since they're not
going to wear it right anyway and the
mask most of the kids are using isn't
even effective against the old variant
not to mention omicron yeah all right
well that's a perfect way to tie up the
whole florida portion so i want to move
a little bit towards national politics
and and what's going on uh right now at
the moment so in these last couple days
obviously we saw this stalemate in the
senate about the voting rights act
you're going to call me crazy i believe
you have to have an id or you should
have an id to vote the democrats
apparently don't believe that and if you
believe it you're racist now there's
this fight over the filibuster you
mentioned a few minutes ago that there
used to sort of be these sane liberals
that you could debate these ideas with
is there anyone left over there i mean i
suspect you probably think joe manchin's
pretty decent at the moment but i mean
when you hear them with these crazy
policies where we're gonna have illegals
voting and you don't have to have an id
to vote but you also have to have a
vaccine card to walk into mcdonald's i
mean do you get behind closed doors with
these guys and go what are you doing
yeah look i think there's more than just
joe manson and chris and cinema that are
don't want to get rid of the filibuster
and think some of these ideas go beyond
their comfort level but if you watch
what's happened to joe manchin and
kirsten cinema when they stepped out
there's a lot of people that are saying
you know what you know i'm just going to
vote with a pack and sort of keep my
head down it's not going to pass anyway
thank god for christian cinema and joe
manchin and so these are people that are
voting yes but hoping for no and and the
fact that two people are willing to step
out and do it kind of gave them the
result they wanted but these guys don't
they don't want to be singled out they
don't want donors threatening them with
primaries they're they're scared and so
i'm not saying that's true of everybody
but yeah there are democrats that view
this as kind of crazy but they're not
going to say it because their base has
become radicalized the people that knock
on doors and make phone calls and and
that they need to mobilize for election
day are demanding whatever the pet issue
or the moment is and they're far outside
the mainstream but if they take those
people on they may not be back and they
certainly don't want the headache
associated with it and so i think as
much as anything else the threats
against kirsten cinema and joe manchin
that you've seen
is not so much about kirsten cinnamon
joe manchin it's a message to the other
senators and other members of congress
who may be thinking about stepping out
of line that this is what awaits you
this is what that's what lies ahead for
you
if you step out of line so just be quiet
and do what we tell you to do
and and and that's that's why i
described it are you surprised that the
leadership folded kind of as quickly as
it did because i'm sure you saw it you
may have been in the chamber at the time
tom cotton did a really spectacular job
of repeating a speech that chuck schumer
gave about the filibuster i think it was
from you know five or eight years ago
something like that uh and then he
announced at the end by the way that was
chuck schumer that wasn't my speech and
it's like i don't think chuck was truly
this radically left and even nancy
pelosi in san francisco like obviously
she had some some of that but i don't
think she was totally like this are you
surprised that they folded not just the
guys that are you know watching out for
their back and just want to get
reelected but but that the leadership
just all went in
on the filibuster well on the filibuster
and yeah that they're following just the
sort of far left on all of this stuff
i'm i'm not actually surprised and uh
and i'll tell you why um so they have
all here's they've got a 50 50 senate a
very narrow majority in the house but
their base thinks they have a mandate to
like transform radically transform
america and so they're getting all this
pressure about get this stuff done and
you go back and say well we can't we
don't have 60 votes and then the base
says to them well then get rid of the 60
vote thing okay because it's standing in
the way of our agenda and get it done
and if you don't get it done then that
means you're not with us and so after a
while they start beating on you so look
that
this fake voting rights thing is just
the issue they picked to have a
filibuster fight over but they were
prepared to do it over the debt ceiling
and they they were at some point talking
about doing it for immigration reform
you name it and they would find the
issue this is just the one they figured
we'd have the best chance to
to make a
straight faced argument on even it
wasn't a very good one and folding on it
i don't think chuck schumer had a choice
i really don't i think if chuck schumer
hadn't done this he was almost certainly
going to be primaried in new york in his
senate race and i think he thought about
that as he went through this cycle i
think that's true for a lot of their
leadership and a lot of the people that
change their position on it at the end
of the day yes they're in the leadership
but they need to win elections to stay
in that leadership and in that case in
case of new york it means a democratic
primary where he most definitely does
not want to take on a far left primary
challenger that could beat him that
could beat him and so he's trying to
avoid that and i think it was pretty
clear to him if he didn't do this that
was without what was what was going to
happen to him yeah and there are even
rumors that aoc might be that person
just to give the devil is due i mean was
there anything in the voting rights act
that you thought was legit or do you
think the entire thing was designed for
all the mail and ballots all the no id
stuff all the illegals like was it all
designed just to keep them in power
forever or was there anything in there i
mean is there anyone in america today
that wants to vote that can't vote for a
legitimate reason or for an illegitimate
i don't think it's ever look i can't
speak for every state
in the union about exactly what their
voting rights and laws are but there are
things in that bill that are mandated
that florida already does we already
have early voting okay we have a 14-day
period a 13-day period of early voting
and then you've got anybody can vote by
mail in florida you don't have to prove
that you're gonna be out of town or
whatever and then you got election day
you go to your precinct and from 7 00 am
to 7 pm as long as you're in line before
7 pm you can vote that way so it's never
been easier but when when i first ran
for office in 2010 there was still you
know early voting was at one point in
the state limited didn't even exist 20
years ago right then when i first voted
in 19 my first election 1989 there was
no early voting if you wanted to vote
absentee you had to write a letter
saying i'm going to be out of town or
i'm having surgery or whatever it is on
that day
and uh so i don't think it's ever been
easier to either register or to vote in
florida so it's not for me the big
problem is first of all there is no
concerted effort to deny access to the
ballot to anyone in america some of
those ideas they're talking about okay
uh you know ballot harvesting allowing
people to go out and just grab ballots
and put them we we had a huge crisis
about that here in florida and by the
way it was in a lot of times in
republican primary races where were
these people you would hire and they
would go out and they would collect 150
200 ballots and and and it just led to
all sort of shenanigans look we had a
mayor's race in miami overturned by a
judge a year after the election because
there was so much massive fraud on the
absentee ballot front a lot of it driven
by ballot harvesting and so we ban those
practices here in florida and the
biggest challenge the biggest problem i
have is this sort of the federal
government is going to take over
elections which is what this is is a
huge problem for me big big problem
because you've now centralized election
authority in america and now it's at the
whim of whoever's in power
well how worried are you that that is
the future of america i mean my main
concern as a new floridian is that we're
going to keep doing things right here
we're going to keep electing the right
officials our businesses are going to
thrive people are going to be out and
about but the federal government simply
will not let us alone it's sort of to
your point earlier about florida did it
right with monoclonal treatment so what
was the federal government response oh
we're going to push tamper down on who
can get it and when they can get it so
what do we do here to make sure that
that sort of ever growing federal
government doesn't
do what i can't even imagine what they
could do but i know there's stuff they
can do yeah you know that's a great
question to a senator because if you
look at the design of the senate the
senate was designed to represent the
states to be the voice of state that's
why every state gets two of them small
states get two of them big states get
two of them and part of our job is to
keep that balance in place between the
federal and state government between the
different levels of government
and oftentimes people think it's not
because i'm against the federal
government doing something on an issue
doesn't mean the issue is not important
i just think the local government or the
state government would do a better job
of dealing with it than the federal
government would it's actually a
fascinating question if you go back to
1500 from the year 1500 forward and you
look at the rise and fall of great
powers there are a lot of reasons why
great powers fall but one of the things
many of those great powers had in common
is they centralized government control
and what that meant is that
entrepreneurial spirit that competition
to see who had better ideas uh that that
creativity and innovation that you would
see when powers decentralized they lost
that they lost it and the places are a
little bit more place one of the key
reasons why europe uh surpassed the asia
pacific region uh in global leadership
because they didn't have a strong
central government that that sort of
quashed that so there's historical
reasons for it i think it's true i think
it's also aligned with our constitution
and look at every innovation in public
education in america over the last 20
years they've all been driven by state
initiatives like school choice and
things of that nature they've all been
driven by at the state level because
states want to have a better education
system than other states so that people
will move their businesses and their
families there and and so i'm going to
work very hard to continue to make sure
that the senate stands in the way of any
effort to have federal takeovers a big
public policy issues of that type so
speaking of federal takeovers biden
obviously gave this big press conference
in the last couple of days um
from where i'm sitting i mean the guy is
not the joe biden of 10 years ago i
think that's a pretty deep
underestimation actually
um do you think he's really running the
show at this point i mean he constantly
at the end of these
press conferences he constantly says oh
i'm not allowed to say that or they
don't want me to say this or they rush
him off or he sits there awkwardly as
people yell questions and he doesn't
answer i mean what do you think is going
on here
yeah i mean i don't know joe biden very
well personally i never served with him
in the senate i i did interact with him
when he was vice president
and obviously you know the person that's
there today is not the same person um
and i i'm in no position to speculate as
to what has changed but it's just not
and that said i mean he has a long
history of sort of saying things that
are silly and gaff prone we know that i
mean that's a well understood dynamic i
think the obama administration
understood that about him as well and um
and and tried to protect him from
himself and certainly administration
from some of those things um where i
think it really becomes relevant look
i'm not one of these people that because
someone misstates a word or doesn't
perfectly phrase something suddenly goes
crazy oh look what they said i mean
that's silly i talked to the camera for
a living i'm with you i'm with you yeah
so i'm not big on that kind of stuff but
i do think there's it's relevant when
you watch this and and you see a
consistent pattern of saying things you
know and in the big speech he gave in
georgia a couple weeks ago he talked
about when he had been arrested it's
been well documented he's never been
arrested in the civil rights protest and
i think if you're vladimir putin or
you're the chinese leadership of the
communist party you're watching that and
saying there's something wrong with this
guy i mean i think there are things we
can get away with as long as that guy is
there and the fact that they would have
the same question that you have who's
actually running the place who's
actually making the decisions
this is a dangerous thing for the
country i mean they had to spend
basically the last 24 hours cleaning up
what he said about ukraine and
you know a partial invasion versus a
full invasion
that's just one element of something he
said on that day
the other is he kind of salute said well
maybe midterms aren't going to be
legitimate they had to clean that up as
well so
um you know i i don't he's not the same
person i don't know who's running the
show i'm in no position to speculate
about that but i can tell you they spent
a lot of time having to sort of clean up
uh things he says and our adversaries
notice it
yeah for sure i mean we've already
talked about the election stuff so we
can let that part of what he said go
because it's sort of
it's basically like they spent four
years under trump questioning elections
now we can't now they're preparing us to
question elections when they get you
know shall act at the end of this year
but on the on the putin ukraine stuff i
thought that was one of the worst few
minutes a president has had at least in
my lifetime but basically just saying
you can kind of do what you want we
don't really know and you pretty much
know we're not going to do anything i
mean what what happened to some level of
deterrence or
a red line perhaps or something like
that
yeah look i mean the most important
thing is we have to explain to people
why this even matters that's a very
legitimate point because i think
americans are very wary of sort of
engaging us and conflicts around the
world so let me be frank i mean there's
not going to be american troops in
ukraine taking on a russian invasion
because you can't really have a
conventional war between two nuclear
powers it's too risky it has the real
danger of escalating and the battlefield
into something it's just not that's not
what anybody's talking about i think
what is important is vladimir putin has
to sit there and we've got to do
everything possible so that he
calculates that the price of doing this
is higher than the benefits he's going
to gain from it and that's not an easy
thing to do because the guy is convinced
that we're going to make nate ukraine a
member nato there are going to be
american missile and troops there at
some point right on his border and so
we've got to change that's how high the
risk is for him we've got to change the
reward pattern on it i think part of
that is economic i think part of it is
you're starting to hear people say it is
the reality that ukrainians aren't going
to welcome these guys and say oh thank
you for taking over our country i mean
they're going to face a protracted
insurgency of ukrainians not americans
of ukrainians you know i don't know what
significant percentage of that
population has
has a history or training or background
and military service and you're gonna
have you know years and years and years
of people taking shots at you and i
think this country as much as any
understands that when you invade a
country you now have to govern and
occupy it and if the people there aren't
that happy they make life miserable for
you it's really it's gonna bleed and
drain the the russian government and
vladimir putin's gonna have to explain
to russian moms why their sons are
coming home in boxes uh for for
because they took over a place that
doesn't want them and those risks have
to be made clear up front in addition to
the economic pain and suffering i i i
believe lyman putin is going to do
something
ideal i think probably the highest
probability is he moves straight into he
goes right after kiev decapitates the
government
he's already setting up the pretext for
it and um and and we just need to make
sure that if he does it he pays a
tremendous price because it's not just
about putin this matters because if he
can get away with it china says well
that's the model for taiwan and you know
maybe north korea says that's the model
for us to take over the entire peninsula
and who else and who knows who else is
thinking about things like this
is that our biggest problem outside of
our borders that if if we don't do
anything nobody else will and sort of
after 20 years of failed nation building
like the american people as you said
people don't want well they certainly
don't want a ground war i don't think
they want any sort of war i don't want a
war i don't want a nation build but i
understand we do have
a unique place in the world and if we're
not the ones kind of saying bad guys you
can't always do whatever you want to do
it's like then all bets are off
yeah look i mean if you're going to be a
country as big and as powerful with an
economy as advanced as ours then what
happens around the world is going to
matter to you because you're sourcing
products you're sourcing raw material
energy
trade commerce
all over the world and so you need there
to be stability the one thing you can
never allow happen for example is let's
say china comes to dominate the
asia-pacific region and so suddenly we
can't trade we we've just lost all those
countries in asia that we sell things to
and buy things from
we have to deal with china and they
decide what to sell or buy from us so a
lot of that's really domestic like we
have to have an industrial capability in
this country we have to have the ability
you cannot be a great power if you're
not in industrial power i i don't care
what people tell you you can't just be
the place that invents things on paper
and then ships it off for someone else
to make it eventually the people making
these things are the people that will
invent them and not to mention the
national security ramifications of it so
number one we have to be in industrial
power number two we have to make sure
that we don't live in a world in which a
great power dominates a region and
basically we have no access to people
that want to trade in commerce with us
that said that has to be balanced
against the notion of over extension
there are a lot of bad things that
happen in the world we need to speak
about it and do what we can but most of
them do not have an american military
solution nor should they in terms of us
getting involved and overextending
ourselves our number one priority must
always be the national interest of our
country and and and um and protecting it
from uh from threats uh both at home and
our interests around the world and it's
like it's a balance that that's that you
have to pull off in public policy but
but to your greater point about no one
else will do it i think a lot of times
what happens is if america isn't
involved then some people will get
involved but they're going to get
involved in ways that may not
necessarily further our national
interest the the withdrawal from
afghanistan for example has led a lot of
countries in the middle to increasingly
turn to china and russia
as their defense
partner preference and and that that's
concerning because that could mean for
the future
of american
economic prosperity and security
do you think some of this is sort of by
design like when you see the way a guy
like say bill de blasio kind of wrecked
new york city which is just an absolute
disaster a place that i lived most of my
adult life before moving to l.a you know
people are like oh you know he this is
an accident like these policies he
didn't realize what was going to happen
but he just gave a speech a couple days
ago where it's like oh no this was great
it's all it's all great here and i feel
the sort of similar way with biden it's
like i don't know that he really thinks
things aren't going well now you look at
the shelves and you look at people's
jobs and everything else and you clearly
realize the price of gas the price of
food etc you realize things aren't but
do you think some of it is actually by
design that it's it's a feature not a
bug in a way of the way they govern
both i think it's the natural
consequence of these decisions they
always lead to disaster but i also don't
think that i think they're not
necessarily overly troubled by it
inflation's a great example inflation if
you believe that you want marxism
socialism and you want the government to
control more of our economy
then inflation isn't necessarily a bad
thing because the way you view it is the
more expensive life gets right the
harder it is to afford things the harder
it is to get child care the harder the
more expensive it is to go to school
the more people are going to be open to
the argument that these things cost too
much the only way you're going to be
able to have it is that the government
provides it for you and so once the
government begins the government doesn't
just take over early childhood education
it decides when it takes it over what's
being taught and who gets to teach it it
doesn't just take over higher education
it decides what you have to teach and
who gets to go it doesn't just take over
when it sends you a
check in the mail
every month you know it doesn't just
decide how much money you have in the
bank it makes you dependent on that
program continuing and having to
increase taxes on other people in order
for the money to be there to do that so
in many ways i think this inflation is
an example and even the supply chain
shortages
create a scenario in which people they
think or become more open to becoming
dependent on government to fill in their
needs because the economy can't do it
only government can do it and that's the
fundamental argument they're making
right is that these are important things
in life
private economy cannot provide it for
you cannot provide you the security only
government can but that always comes at
the price of your freedom and liberty
both economic and personal
yeah and that's what i mean about
feature not a bug it's like a guy like
de blasio he wrecked new york city but
in his view it's like oh but the
government's doing more now so thus this
is good and i think that that's sort of
what's going on all over the place so to
that point uh obviously there's midterms
coming you know everybody's talking
about some some big red
wave or something i'm pretty sure we're
going to be safe here
in florida do you by the way do you say
florida or florida i'm a new yorker
originally so i say florida you say
everyone's saying florida here but i
also say orange juice not orange juice
so i don't know no no one's ever i mean
i've heard about nevada and nevada but
i've never heard of florida in florida i
don't know what i say florida
i don't know you say florida i say
florida i people are telling me it's in
new york then we say florida we say
orange instead of orange but what do you
what do you think is going to happen in
in this uh midterm situation i mean do
you think we can actually capture i mean
we i never would have said we before but
i think it's we at this point uh you
know get the house back it sounds like
the senate's gonna do pretty well and
what do you what do you say well the
easiest way to lose at anything is to
think is to act like you're winning so i
think that's the first thing we have to
keep in mind the second is i mean
these guys raise a lot of money okay as
an example right chuck schumer went out
and hand-picked val demings the
congresswoman from central florida was
just a puppet of nancy pelosi and said
that's who i want to be our candidate in
florida and she's raising 10 million
dollars a quarter or more online just
sending out an email so they're going to
raise that kind of money for candidates
i mean every senate republican incumbent
was outraged in in 2020 and in 2018. so
we can't overlook the fact that these
people are going to outraise us we're
also not going to get any benefit from
media as a perfect example okay i was
ranked the most effective republican
senator by the vanderbilt university of
virginia uh
program that looks at the effectiveness
of members of congress another group
again nonpartisan ranked me the second
number two in leadership score passed a
bunch of really meaningful bills not the
least of which was the creation of the
paycheck protection program that
literally saved millions of small
business jobs in this country you
wouldn't know that i mean
a week ago a couple weeks ago it was my
work and having to blow up the defense
bill that got
forced nancy pelosi in the house to pass
a bill that banned the import of
products made by uyghur slave laborers
none of that stuff is reported on the
media is is a real challenge for us
because they're not we're we're they're
not going to report on our
accomplishments or accurately in many
cases to put out what we're working on
or what our position is on these issues
and uh so so i wouldn't take that for
granted either so these guys are going
to have more money and they're going
gonna have the benefit of mainstream
media so we're gonna have to work real
hard to make sure that our base knows
what's going on that people turn out and
vote do i feel good about the direction
of florida do i feel good about the fact
that people are realizing joe biden is a
disaster absolutely but we put the
election isn't today it's in november
we've got a long ways to go between now
and then we've got to make sure that
people keep learning not just about what
they're doing wrong but what we're going
to do right if they give us the chance
to be in the position of controlling the
senate house
so putting aside politics uh as as we
get close to wrap here um you know we've
talked a couple times before and i know
all about your family's story of coming
here and your dad washing dishes and and
the whole thing and then you rise to
become a senator it's exactly what the
american story is are you still hopeful
for that story because so much of what
we hear
is designed at destroying that story
that the whole purpose of this country
was based on systemic racism that that's
the founding principle i mean all the
all the woke nonsense when you get
through all that are you still hopeful
that the dream that your parents came
here with is still available to other
people and that we can actually
strengthen them yeah i am in fact i'm
not just hopeful about it i think that's
our destiny as a country but we're
constantly reinventing ourselves and
when you reinvent yourself and i mean
that in a positive way reinvigorate
yourself really is the term
it gets messy and conflictive you know
in every generation every 30 40 years we
have some group of people that rise in
politics and say you know this america
thing isn't actually that good it isn't
as good as people make it out to be we
really need to change we really can't
continue to do these sorts of things and
it gets traction for a little while
because they take advantage of some you
know peculiarity of the moment but
eventually what happens is that the
overwhelming majority of americans
including people that don't agree on a
lot of issues right people may not agree
on what the tax rate should be or
whatever but they generally agree on one
thing and that is look guys what we have
here is pretty good i wouldn't rather be
anybody else and we can't walk away from
the things that made it that way and we
got to build on that i think that's what
you see that's happening right now okay
i think that's what you see happening
right now there are a lot of people out
there that voted for joe biden maybe
didn't like donald trump maybe you've
never voted for a republican
but they don't understand why their kids
are being pulled out of school okay they
got a four-year-old
they're on their fifth 10-day quarantine
even though their child is tested
negative because some kid in class and
nobody's you know and contested positive
and no one seems to care or listening to
that there are people that are saying
look my kid has really not been in a
stable learning environment for two
years how are we going to make that up
and what's that going to mean down the
road and in the future there are small
business owners many of whom maybe are
you know liberal democrats but they're
like i can't hire anybody and if i hire
someone they hire them on monday
thursday they just stop showing up and
all my products cost more and i can't
pass it through to the consumer so
there's an awakening going on in this
country about the consequences of these
policies and sometimes it's messy and
it's loud but i i would say this who
would i trade places with who would you
trade places well there's no country in
the world i look at and i say i wish i
were that instead of us
and i we build on that so yes the raw
elements there's nothing the american
people are would be fine it's our
government that's broken it's a people
making decisions at the highest levels
of corporate america that are broken not
our people and uh and and it's going to
take some time to work its way through
to the top
all right senator one more for you on
that note actually so as uh mayor suarez
down here in miami said in that famous
tweet i believe it was to keith raboy
when he was considering moving to
florida mayor suarez says what can i do
to help well hey i'm a new floridian man
what can i do to help you right here and
by me i mean i mean literally me but i
mean anyone watching this and especially
anyone that lives right here well at the
what can we do to help yeah i mean at
the expense of sounding shameless as i
just pointed out i mean i've got an
opponent running against me that's out
raising me online you know
donors from all over the country
honestly these msnbc binge watchers that
are sending stuff in the mail so i just
ask people if they can to go on marco
rubio.com marco rubio.com and give
whatever you can because i need that
help to get our word out and our message
out and i think beyond that it's just
continue to be a platform like you've
done where people can speak truths where
people can hear from uh the people not
just in office but people that are in
the periphery of politics but who have
opinions on these issues and a lot it's
become harder than ever to have these
sort of long-form conversations and
nuanced conversations so people can hear
what we actually stand for and have
debate maybe there's a disagreement
about what people stand for nowadays
it's harder than ever i mean it really
is i mean you just can't get a message
out anymore on legacy media and it's
platforms like this that that are
protecting the first amendment and
making that possible so keep doing what
you're doing with that florida flair now
that you're down here and talking about
what really is happening down here and
hopefully that'll inspire people across
the country to elected people and follow
the direction we followed here
well senator i'm pretty sure not totally
sure i'm pretty sure i can speak for all
of my staff that you have at least eight
new votes in florida good that have just
moved here and we're going to see what
else we can do it was a pleasure talking
to you as always i appreciate the time
hey thanks for having me on welcome to
florida
thanks if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell